when is a language a language what
constitutes a language
and I sort of am thinking about this
question as I'm heading off on my trip
to Denmark Sweden and Poland
and I've been practicing my Danish and
my polish my Swedish is already fairly
good
and so then I think to myself well
Danish and Swedish and Norwegian are
very very close they're kind of mutually
comprehensible the Danes have an easier
time understanding the swedes and the
Norwegians the swedes have a harder time
understanding the Danes but essentially
the vocabulary is very very similar the
structure is very very similar and yet
they are recognized as separate
languages
now I move on to polish which I've been
essentially only listening to and
reading and I don't know how I'm going
to do there I will certainly do some
videos when I'm in Poland uh you know in
Denmark I might do some videos and
you'll see that I'll still be speaking
Swedish but they'll understand me I've I
don't think I'll be pronouncing Danish
but when I'm in Poland I'm in a totally
different language system so if I'm
going to try to say anything I'm gonna
have to say it in Polish now
I know other Slavic languages but
they're sufficiently different and no
one suggests that polish is actually
Czech or Ukrainian or it's a separate
language there is no issue there
whatsoever but these languages influence
each other so if you say take check and
slow back now those are considered
separate languages but they're so
similar that checks and slovaks have
absolutely no difficulty understanding
understanding each other so why is that
two separate languages question all
right a similar situation uh occurs in
in the Balkans
where okay Slovenian is somewhat of an
outlier but Bosnian Serbian Croatian are
so similar that probably
you know differences within those
countries can be as great as the
differences between those languages and
yet there are some people who say well I
speak you know I'm a Serbian I don't
speak Croatian uh but a majority of
people there from what I've heard agree
that it's essentially one language
although Serbian does can use the
Cyrillic alphabet but also does use the
Latin alphabet at times I don't fully
understand why they use the one or the
other
um also in the Balkans you have
Macedonian and Bulgarian that are very
similar again I don't speak either of
those languages so so you start to see
where
sort of the political situation
tends to
determine whether a form of a language
is considered a language in other words
is there a country there uh but that's
not necessarily clear either because you
know in Canada we have
the people in Quebec and in New
Brunswick and elsewhere in Canada who
speak French but we have two languages
so it's a bilingual country the the
situation of Ukrainian there are people
in Russia who don't want to admit that
the Ukrainian language exists when in
fact the I don't know the full story of
the evolution of Ukrainian and and the
Belarusian language I think they were
essentially the ruthenian language and
that was one form of say Eastern Slavic
languages and Russian it was a sort of a
different form and the uh
lexical distance in other words the
vocabulary uh as between you know
Russian and Ukraine is actually more
distant than say the relationship
between Ukrainian and polish getting
back to my polish situation and of
course there are all kinds of historical
reasons why that's the case if we look
at at Asia for example
there's 90 million speakers of Cantonese
yet Cantonese is it a language or is it
a dialect the interesting thing is that
most Cantonese speakers
consider themselves to be Chinese and
are not that interested in having a
separate language status for Cantonese
to the best of my knowledge some do but
a majority don't the ones that I have
met they don't make a big deal out of of
the fact that Cantonese is a separate
language they're happy to speak
Cantonese they have Cantonese radio but
they're Chinese and they speak Chinese
um you know in Taiwan you have this
minan language which is also spoken in
the southern part of fujian province
that seems to be more recognized as a
separate language although again I can't
I'm not an expert so maybe it's just
considered a dialect of of Chinese you
often hear Chinese languages what I
would consider to be languages are
considered dialects because that's how
the people who speak those languages
seem to look upon them
from what I can tell
I'm not knowledgeable about differences
between Indonesian and and Malaysian for
example or you know Thai and and Laotian
or any of those situations I'm not at
all familiar with them uh so at what
point is it a language at what point is
it a dialect if you go back to Europe of
course
uh there used to be a lot more Regional
languages in France and Italy and
Germany for example
and then gradually there was this sort
of centralizing Trend in the 19th
century in particular as part of the
sort of national Awakening so the
Germans are ought to have one language
the French have got to have one language
and they and the Italians and they ended
up essentially
discouraging and in some cases
depressing or even forbidding people
from speaking these Regional languages
in Spain the regional languages seem to
have survived better so Catalan and uh
and the Gallego Galician
is still there as a regional language
within the romance group of course
Basque is a another Regional language
and even within the Catalan language
some people in the Balearic Islands or
Valencia say that their language is
different is a different language or is
it Catalan again I don't know I'm not in
those discussions but there is a sort of
sort of subjective nature as to what we
consider to be a language
um you know I I have no familiarity with
not wattle for example in Mexico but I
understand that there are some
interesting situations with Navajo or
guarani in Paraguay that they're most
closely related sort of native North or
Native American language may not be the
one that's nearby but sometimes there's
one from further away but they are
certainly recognized as languages here
we have the case of Esperanto there is
no Esperanto country but people who
speak Esperanto feel very strongly that
it's an important language so maybe
the decision on whether something is a
language or not or a dialect that should
depend on what the speakers of that
language think and believe
uh I think if if the speaker of a
certain language says I speak language X
it's a language it's not a dialect
I think we have to accept that
and if that is then if that gains
General acceptance then not only is the
speaker of that language saying it's not
a dialect it's a language but if we
accept it then it gains General
acceptance and then that then becomes a
language and not a dialect but it's it's
a difficult situation you know people
might refer to say the Haitian uh what
do they call it the Creole uh but
sometimes the term Patois used to
describe a sort of you know a hybrid
language
but look at the languages of Europe that
um you know emanated from from Latin uh
in France and in in Spain and so forth
the Iberian Peninsula they must have
been some form of patwa even English
which is a hodgepodge mixture of
I guess there's some Celtic words in
there I don't know but predominantly
Germanic words and and words not So Much
from the Romans it turns out but more
from the Norman French and out of that
Evolution Patois whatever you want to
call it uh came the language that is
known today as English so the fact that
a language is a mixture of other
languages or that is an a sort of
process of evolution none of that is is
disqualifying none of that is strange
it's all a part of how languages evolve
and uh ultimately the decision on
whether
a Patois or a Creole or a dialect is a
language or not becomes and remains
quite subjective so I look forward to
lots of comment from people who know a
lot more about this subject than I do
thank you for listening